こんにちははず店長です20歳以上の皆様お酒を飲みますでしょうか
あーせなきゃいけません二十歳を超えとお酒を飲むまで多いと思うんですよ大学飲み会
とか
会社の宴会飲み会打ち上げとかいろいろあると思うんですけども僕はありません
何度を下げを飲む機会は全然ないんですけどもハマーなことのやっぱね美味しいも先
っていうのがあるんですよ
エボ久喜本店甘党なんでこのカシスオレンジとのばっかり飲んじゃうんですけども
もっともっとおいしいお席が存在するんじゃないかなと思いまして今回店でお先になっ
ていないようなのにもたくさんスーパーで買ってきました
オレンジジュースのお酒とかコーラ割りとか
ウーロン割りとか色々あるんですけどもなんか見たことない奴結構あったってたんで
ひょっとしたらこの事実を下げにしたらおいしい札っていうのが発見されてないかも
しれないと思ったのでちょっと今回それを探していこうと思いますでお先の仕方なん
ですけども
高精度を使っていますスピに達すと皆さんこれ知ってますでしょうかあれコール96%
ですちょっと乗ってみましょう96%何であるのだ
学校板をダルくならバトルと思うんですけどもうあのアルコールランプみたいなある
ことだとの下の駅ですね方開きだす
[音楽]
わー
re
ううううくれなかったよ
こういう意味で濃いのでこれをちょっとだけ出るともう先になる音そのものを持って
ちょっとまだ発見されていない美味しいお酒を今日は作っていきましょう
れないと意気込む入ってあげて早速作っていきましょう結局ですね美味しいお酒っての
も発見されているから新しく作るからすごい大変だと思うんですよね
まずはこちらライフガードから飲んでいきましょうっぽくさっき言ったろ
だけ弱いんでこのどうか最後までちゃんと撮れるが鞄なんですよねちょっと良い潰れ
ないように気をつけながら飲んでいこうと思いますじゃあライフガード終わり
飲んでみましょう
入りすぎたね入りすぎたねやばいよこれからみんな96%ては去ってます今入れただけ
でこれでお酒10%くらい必要があります
voodoo
うまえめうめうめライフガードした決まったらめっちゃねーぞこれけっこう張りライフ
カード
次行きましょうこれは何ですね合いそうなんだよな cc でも入れてみますネ申歌集
的なイメージになる気がするんですよね
見えて来ないように気をつけますあぁこんな方からいただきます
氷結ストロング前はこれもちょっとありきたりつありきたりなんですけどもファンタ
オレンジに出てみましょう生田絵梨花ちゃんだ
8位まあこれもどせいか室オレンジ的なコンビニとかで売ってそうな感じになると思う
よね入れます
入れすぎたの無形の long 型の
どうぞん
ほぼカシオレなんかここら辺はまぁ元が美味しいじゃないいいですよ
さぁ続いてはコレですね
なにこれボディ面でというやつを飲んでみましょうかパパリセットの友達ぽいですね
コンディショニングドリンクです体のコンディションを整える
飲料体のコンディション別後は性暴力団コール
私そのスタッフまず的な逃がしになるのでしょうか
イヤーッ
[音楽]
ん
したらスポーツドリングって後政権の周りを早くするって聞いたんですけどそれもなん
かすごい最速バージョンダメ水デスクラック
先に飲んどけばよかった宇高乗ってからお酒飲み過ぎた時様のイメージが強いんで
色がすごいを卵ですね
ここが小須田やばいもう限界ますね
お酒を倒す力と協力のを下げどっちが競り方でしょうか
分離とかしないよねめっちゃなく当て逃げ杉田早いいただきます
ていた
4分
じゃくちーた何ねっ
クソまずいです続いてあの pht 飲んでみましょう bht
日本酒はだが歯茎がするんですよねを持つ悪いみたいなもんですからね
いきます
いただきます
[音楽]
アンウェーブ uma 聞いちゃいますねなんかセクシーな女が人の味がしますね
匂いがいいですねなんかこういう香りがせるを鳴らせばいたら僕はすごく保護します
甘いです続いてはこちら
麦茶ウーロン割りとがよく聞くんですけども麦茶割りあんま聞いてもないと思うんだ
けどなんかどうでしょうもに味見なる気がすんだなぁをちゃってさまだ甘いというそう
いうか
じゃないんで
水着だ見ただけなん
[音楽]
ん
2助けて誰か能文けどね
続いてこちらですねそれって飯田市まあこの先に夏の帰省になってるの皆さん外にだと
汗かくと思うんですよ畔を書くと水分がなくなってしまって何とかす妹に入り今虚脱妹
に選んでるだけなキャメルとスタートリング社と入れたりして体なんてのは困難か
しよう
なあとに2種は小遣い管理制御でなきゃだとにも帰って使用が減ってるような子それに
入れてみたらこれホント
しっかりで夏バテというか脱水症状を抑えられると言われております盗んでみましょう
その ti ちゃんはう気がしますね open うどんキートーンと入れ過ぎちゃっ
た
ヤリまん
ん
持ってい
くってきてきて行ってきてていい
ぎゃーか働くクラクラしてきますやっぱこんなスポーツという芸は酔いが回りが早い
そうそうそうこれもの多いシーンがわかってる気がしますねデカビタ
一番会社こういうのはにゃんもうまいとかわかってるんだったらもう味はよりゃ
湯ねー寂れすぎちゃったいいい
ん
何すぎた皆さんでも全然美味しいですよあゆりのなし
いたしました全然大丈夫ですよ続いてはこちらキレートレモンを飲んでみましょう
もうこんくらいでいいと思いますいただきます
馬キレートレモンめっちゃおいしいわかんなくねきれいと裏面
英語っぽくなっちまったぜなかなか良いですねまあね者とを下げてありますねっ
水仙こちらウイダーinゼリーそれぞれ10秒チャージなんですけどもを下げを異例と
10秒を下げちゃってができるわけですからアートに一気飲みを推奨しているわけでは
ないの皆さんご了承くださいませ宜しくお願いします
だいたいたーーー10秒レコロチャージだと
いただきます
うーんあは次あう医大のプロテインタイプです
入っちゃいます
[音楽]
んあああああああああああ
次はどれにしようかなもう
だ
パシッ ere
者さんおいしいがねぇさあ動揺し何箇所かいだいまー
me
うっうードゥ
いっ
ブーブーマミーで雨 au ドゥロワーヌー美味しいと大評判でありますウードゥー
あ
置くときどんなすごい遠い自分で自分の首を絞めてゆくー見かけねー
それではこっちだブラックコーヒーブーブーエスパダ
[音楽]
あとちょっとはまぁ頑張っての部屋はミルクティーですねミルクて普通日本しそうな気
がしますねバイバイ入れすぎたましたがせっかく魅力美味しいのに台無しにされたく
ないなぁ
うまいと噛み合うことを祈って飲んでみましょういただきます
ガウ
飲みやすう撮影バナナオレ挙げてみましょう
なんかそういう音カクテルありそうな気もしますけどどんなこと大臣とぜってーは気が
すんだよなバナナオレ様だって俺
美味しくないわけがないと思いたいです
いただきます
[音楽]
my レベル毎にちょっとも味がよくわかんない人に設けせません猫は海からうん
ああああああああハ
ザー残り二つとなりましたクロスと飲むヨーグルトですね
なんか牛乳割りとかってさぁなんかさぁありきたりだなぁと思ってどのヨーグルトした
んですけど
84人台に登って動いたわけですね
わー白いそりゃそうだ飲むヨーグルト無作為れると
軍吏とましたところだった
ああとろっとろってした美馬ワクワクしてきたよ
いただきます
うんなぁな雷前なさいのクロスですねクロス搭載の組み合わせなんて僕とか聞いたこと
ないんでどんな人間かすごい楽しみですね話してどんな水なのでしょうか
クロスとお酒の味の全4章なります
[音楽]
まあな金がある前ふーん
me
うううう
ええええええ
あっはぁ